two and a half hours outside of Seattle
in this sleepy little town of Yakima
Washington lies a hidden Empire and what
they've been making you've used your
entire life it's like one of those
things that you go oh my god I did that
that was invented oh yeah Wow
my name is Stephanie and I'm the oldest
of the paxton women my name is Kimberly
and I'm in the middle my name is Melissa
and I am the baby
[Music]
we are the three sisters behind the
kwik-lok Corporation and the little bag
closures that you see just about
everywhere and by everywhere she means
everywhere typically around bread but it
can be found on a variety of packages
from produce to potatoes we sell
billions of quick locks a year billion
[Laughter]
the invention of the little closures
that could dates back to their
grandfather
Floyd Paxton the story certainly is that
our grandfather whittled his first click
clock out of a credit card whether or
not that is actual fact we'll probably
never be discovered but the bag closure
business isn't all fun and games I would
say our biggest competition is the wire
tie you know the thing that you have to
twist that you can't untwist or get it
all mixed up oh yeah those things never
thought about it but if we're being
honest I guess I never really thought
about bag closures in general
[Music]
it's always so fun telling the story of
the quick lock that this little plastic
square closure that was invented in
Yakima Washington and it's gone from
this little town to being sold globally
in international
[Music]